here's why i think jagged little pill is
such an amazing accomplishment
what you did was completely change your
image you started out you put out an
album you were touring with vanilla ice
right
i opened for vanilla ice how old were
you when you did that i was 14.
14 you open for vanilla ice vanilla ice
is like the biggest act on the planet
yes
and you're a go-getter you're not only
on tv but you're writing songs and stuff
but the songs when you were a kid kind
of sounded like this let's uh remind
everyone where you were at
this is party boy right yeah
that's like a pop thing that a kid would
put out yeah
and that's where you were at you were a
kid you were you were a little girl 15.
[Music]
it doesn't even i mean it doesn't even
sound like what you became
right a little of the tone a little bit
you can hear the tone
so what i find amazing is you did make
the transition
what you did was you shed your pop star
clothing so to speak and you said i'm
gonna go write music that's more
important to me that goes against what
my image is
and let's face it if you had gone the
pop route like a lot of the kids did
you probably wouldn't have been as
successful but i'm sure people were
pushing you to do that yes and when i
started to write autobiographically and
really it was more self-led so to speak
like i just stopped wanting to be
presentational i love
performance right i mean bring the
glitter bring the lights but i need i
need it
to be conversational and i wouldn't stop
until i met
someone who was sitting across from me
collaboratively pretty sorry who would
say
who are you weren't people though like
record encouraging you not to write
they were they were terrified of what
you brought me from mca in canada
because i was
making the move towards self right and
they said no no no i don't think anyone
around you wants this from you
can you imagine uh somewhere there's
some executive who passed on your new
direction
and it ended up being this fabulous
album that is by the way this is why we
celebrate it not only is it the 20th
anniversary of this album
it is the 20th biggest selling album in
the history of music isn't it
i didn't know that i knew that how come
i know that because you do research and
my head is at my butt so and you sold 30
million albums but can you imagine the
guy from mca who said hey she's going in
this weird direction
she thinks she can write her own music
and stuff let's drop her let's drop her
really good move right
there were a few people that were
shaking their heads and admonishing me
for
moving toward i think the specific thing
they were freaked out about
i did a video where i had snakes and i
was coming into my body and
they were freaked out by that yeah and
then and then some of them were freaked
out literally by the lack of rhyming
so you go off and you start writing uh
your own music
and and you collaborate how did you find
glenn the guy who collaborated on uh
jagged little pill was a perfect
collaboration for you glenn uh
ballard right ballard uh how do you find
this guy
because here you are like a 19 year old
girl writing songs and he's a 40
something year old guy why glenn ballard
why was there such a connection when you
sat down to write this album i'd been
writing with a lot of people ha
leading up to having matt glenn and
there weren't a lot of matches there
were a lot of fun
laughing times but no songs that really
felt like me and then
so you were searching for a partner to
write with specifically a partner
who could sit across from me and swallow
their ego but still be empowered
right and just follow what was being
begged of us in the moment
swallow their ego because you were going
to it was going to be the alanis mara
set album
it had to be if it was my name that's
right and it was going to be you know
you were going to get the the you know
you were going to be the performer so
the person
who writes with you has to swallow their
ego and allow you to be the front person
exactly in the same way that if you and
i were writing a record and it was your
record i would swallow my ego and
and just basically serve you and we know
how hard that is to do right
um depends on whether you're a collab if
you're a real collaborator you go back
and forth all the time
so glenn is the first person you meet
who really
gets you and says you know what i can
swallow my ego let's make this all about
you atlantis
and he you wrote 99 of the lyrics
on the album uh you wrote some of the
music and glenn wrote some of the music
is that how it works
we wrote music together ironic was the
only one we wrote lyrics together in the
demos on this deluxe package
we wrote all the lyrics together and
then after ironic i started writing
lyrics alone with the song perfect and
ironic is funny because uh you gotta you
still get to this day because
everyone goes hey alain
that's not real irony in this song but
you were like hey i'm 19. i don't you
know i'm just trying to come up with a
song
right is that it glenn and i were trying
to make each other laugh and i also
think at the time
see there's a part of me that's quite
aware that i'm very stupid
very very dumb you didn't know the
definition of ironic most people don't
and do and then there's another part of
me that's really smart i did not care i
honestly thought maybe a hundred people
would hear this song
right um malapropisms what are you gonna
do right but the interestingly enough
the dictionary actually this kills me
about pop culture the dictionary
changed the definition based on i can't
say singularity on me but i think
based on people being so confused about
the definition of irony
and i am usually a stickler for grammar
so it was a step out
for me you almost didn't put this song
on the album you didn't like this song
you thought it was bad do you think you
thought it was bad because glenn had
written some of the lyrics for it
i didn't like it because it wasn't
autobiographical
hey
is this one of those instances too where
they you guys recorded this in like 15
minutes
no is that true isn't that crazy it is
crazy
i just like the course did you put it on
the album
if you didn't like it i love the chorus
that's what that's what sold it to you
15 people around me said basically
begged
to keep the song i reckon i thought wow
if they're that freaked out let's just
put it on
were you shocked when the song became
one of your hits yes you were
yes you had no idea it shows you really
don't know i'm clueless
yeah most artists are they don't know
what they're hitting
[Applause]
love that show
you